This episode of Casefile is sponsored by BetterHelp. Life can get busy with work, family and everything else on your plate. It's easy to let your priorities slip, even the ones that make you feel your best. But when your schedule feels overwhelming it's more important than ever to make time for your non-negotiables, like therapy. Whether you're looking to build positive coping skills, set boundaries, or just want to become the best version of yourself, therapy can help. If you've been thinking about starting therapy, consider giving BetterHelp a try. It's an online platform designed to be convenient, flexible, and tailored to your schedule. You simply fill out a brief questionnaire and better help will match you with a licensed
本期 Casefile 节目由 BetterHelp 赞助。生活总是被工作、家庭和其他琐事填满，忙得不可开交。我们很容易忽略那些真正重要的事，甚至是那些能让你感觉最好的事。但当你的日程安排让你感到不堪重负时，抽出时间来处理那些不可妥协的事情（比如心理咨询）就显得尤为重要。无论你是想培养积极的应对技巧、设定界限，还是只想成为最好的自己，心理咨询都能为你提供帮助。如果你一直在考虑开始心理咨询，不妨试试 BetterHelp。它是一个在线平台，旨在为你提供便捷、灵活且量身定制的服务。你只需填写一份简短的问卷，BetterHelp 就会为你匹配一位持证
therapist. Plus, if you feel the need to switch therapists, you can do so at any time with no extra cost. The team at Casefile are firm believers in the benefits of therapy. It's not just for those who have experienced major trauma. Therapy can teach you coping skills, help you set boundaries and give you the space to explore your thoughts and feelings without judgement. Never skip Therapy Day with BetterHelp. Visit betterhelp.com slash case file today to get 10% off your first month. That's better help. H-E-L-P dot com slash case file. Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre.
治疗师。此外，如果你觉得需要更换治疗师，可以随时更换，无需额外费用。Casefile 团队坚信心理咨询的益处。它不仅仅适用于那些经历过重大创伤的人。心理咨询可以教你应对技巧，帮助你设定界限，并为你提供一个空间，让你在不受评判的情况下探索自己的想法和感受。千万不要错过 BetterHelp 的心理咨询日。立即访问 betterhelp.com/casefile，首月可享 10% 的折扣。网址是 betterhelp.com/casefile。我们的节目涉及严肃且往往令人不安的事件。如果你在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系当地的危机中心。
For suggested phone numbers for confidential support and for a more detailed list of content warnings, please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. In late 2019, bank examiner Emery Wilson was settling into his new home on South Waverly Drive in Dallas, Texas when he was approached by a middle-aged man and woman. They introduced themselves as married couple Jamie and Jennifer Faith. The Faiths lived five doors down and had arrived to give Emery a gift to warmly welcome him to their neighbourhood. As Emery came to learn, this friendly and courteous act was typical of the Faiths. The two were known for genuinely caring about others and always doing the right thing. They even handed out the PIN code
如需获取保密支持的建议电话号码以及更详细的内容警告列表，请查看你所用应用程序或我们网站上的本期节目说明。2019 年底，银行审查员埃默里·威尔逊（Emery Wilson）刚搬进位于德克萨斯州达拉斯市南韦弗利大道（South Waverly Drive）的新家，就有一对中年男女走近他。他们自我介绍说是已婚夫妇杰米·费思（Jamie Faith）和詹妮弗·费思（Jennifer Faith）。费思夫妇住在离他五户远的地方，他们特意过来送上一份礼物，热烈欢迎他搬进这个社区。埃默里后来了解到，这种友好和礼貌的行为是费思夫妇的典型作风。两人以真心关怀他人、总是做正确的事而闻名。他们甚至把大门的
to their gate so that neighbours could use their swimming pool or hot tub whenever they liked. Just like everyone else who met them, Emery Wilson came to like the Faiths. else who met them, Emery Wilson came to like the Faiths. Both were highly successful in their respective careers, with Jamie a Director of Technology for American Airlines and Jennifer a distinguished speech therapist. They were also loving and supportive parents to their college-aged daughter. Emery sometimes encountered the Faiths when they crossed paths while out walking their respective dogs. This happened more often in 2020 when the COVID-19 pandemic hit and Emory started working remotely from home. He was there on the morning of Friday October 9, 2020, when all of a sudden his quiet suburban surroundings were disrupted by multiple rapid
密码告诉了邻居，这样邻居们就可以随时使用他们的游泳池或热水浴缸。就像所有见过他们的人一样，埃默里·威尔逊也喜欢上了费思夫妇。两人在各自的职业生涯中都非常成功，杰米是美国航空公司的技术总监，詹妮弗是一位杰出的言语治疗师。他们也是充满爱心、给予支持的父母，有一个上大学的女儿。埃默里有时会在遛狗时与费思夫妇偶遇。这种情况在 2020 年新冠疫情爆发、埃默里开始远程居家办公后变得更加频繁。2020 年 10 月 9 日星期五早上，他正在家中，突然，他安静的郊区环境被几声急促的
fire bangs, followed by blood curdling screams. I'm going to dropped to the floor and moved away from the windows. The sound was out of place in the otherwise peaceful and family-oriented neighbourhood. Emery could hear a woman screaming in abject terror until she managed to form the words, Help me, help me. Realising someone was still in danger, Emery rushed outside. A large Bernese Mountain dog was running freely in the road with its lead trailing behind. Emery recognised it as Jamie and Jennifer Faith's beloved dog, Maggie. Emory peered out from behind a wall in the direction of the screaming and called out, what happened? He couldn't see anything, so he cautiously moved across his lawn to the sidewalk. From there, he could see a pair of legs sprawled out on the
枪响打破，随后传来令人毛骨悚然的尖叫声。我趴到地板上，远离窗户。在原本宁静且以家庭为导向的社区里，这种声音显得格格不入。埃默里能听到一个女人在极度恐惧中尖叫，直到她断断续续地喊出：“救救我，救救我。”意识到有人仍处于危险之中，埃默里冲了出去。一只大型伯恩山犬在路上自由奔跑，牵引绳拖在身后。埃默里认出这是杰米和詹妮弗·费思心爱的狗——玛吉（Maggie）。埃默里从墙后探出头，朝着尖叫声的方向喊道：“发生了什么事？”他什么也看不见，于是小心翼翼地穿过草坪来到人行道上。从那里，他可以看到有一双腿横躺在
street near the Faith's residence. Other curious neighbours had emerged from their homes. Emery yelled at them, call the police. Emery raced towards the body to render assistance, only to be stopped in his tracks just two houses down. Suddenly, a male figure stepped onto the sidewalk a few feet ahead. The man turned and looked at Emery. He had the hood of his jacket pulled down over his forehead and a blue fabric face mask covered the lower half of his face. Emery briefly locked eyes with the man before noticing that he was clutching a silver handgun at his right side. Panicked, Emery sprinted back to his house to collect his own firearm. He re-emerged ready for a confrontation, but the gunman was gone.
离费思家不远的街道上。其他好奇的邻居也从家里出来了。埃默里对他们大喊：“报警！”埃默里冲向尸体想要提供帮助，却在离他家仅两户远的地方停下了脚步。突然，一个男性身影出现在前方几英尺的人行道上。那人转过身看着埃默里。他戴着连帽衫的兜帽，遮住了前额，蓝色的布口罩遮住了脸的下半部分。埃默里与那人短暂地对视了一眼，随后注意到他右手紧握着一把银色手枪。惊慌失措的埃默里跑回自己家去拿枪。他再次出现准备对峙，但枪手已经不见了。
Emery realised that the body sprawled out on the street was that of 49-year-old Jamie Faith. He lay unmoving near the sidewalk in a growing pool of blood, clearly deceased. Emery found Jamie's 48-year-old wife Jennifer sheltering behind a fence in a neighbour's driveway. She was hysterical and clearly terrified, repeating, No one came. no one came. Emory reassured her that police were on their way, saying soothingly, we're here. Officers arrived within minutes to find South Waverly Drive in a state of chaos with the Jamie Faiths lifeless body at the centre. His wife Jennifer was visibly
埃默里意识到躺在街上的尸体是 49 岁的杰米·费思。他一动不动地躺在人行道附近，身下是一滩不断扩大的血泊，显然已经死亡。埃默里发现杰米 48 岁的妻子詹妮弗正躲在邻居车道的一道栅栏后。她歇斯底里，显然被吓坏了，不停地重复着：“没有人来，没有人来。”埃默里安慰她说警察正在赶来，轻声说道：“我们在这儿。”警察在几分钟内赶到，发现南韦弗利大道一片混乱，杰米·费思毫无生气的尸体就在中心。他的妻子詹妮弗显然
distraught and in a state of shock. While she struggled to convey what had happened, officers ascertained that the Faiths had left their home at around 7.30am to take their dog Maggie on her daily walk. They'd barely left the driveway when someone ran up behind them and began shooting without saying a word. Jamie was hit several times before falling to the ground. The offender then stood over Jamie and fired more rounds into his body before turning his attention to Jennifer as she attempted to flee. According to Jennifer, one witness had seen the shooter aim his gun at her and pull the trigger, only to realise it was out of bullets. The shooter then sprinted after Jennifer, tackled her to the ground, and unleashed a violent attack. Between punches,
心烦意乱，处于休克状态。当她努力讲述发生了什么时，警察确定费思夫妇是在早上 7 点 30 分左右离开家，带他们的狗玛吉进行日常散步。他们刚离开车道，就有人从后面跑过来，一言不发地开始射击。杰米身中数枪后倒地。凶手随后站在杰米上方，又向他的身体开了几枪，然后将注意力转向试图逃跑的詹妮弗。据詹妮弗说，有一位目击者看到枪手将枪对准她并扣动了扳机，却发现子弹打光了。枪手随后冲向詹妮弗，将她扑倒在地，并展开了暴力袭击。在拳打脚踢之间，
he managed to duct tape Jennifer's hands together and attempted to pull off her wedding ring. By this point, Jennifer's screams had alerted her neighbours, prompting the gunman to flee empty-handed. Because the duct tape was cut into two small lengths, Jennifer was able to free herself rather easily and to take shelter. Other than some minor bumps, bruises and scrapes, she was mostly unheard. Her wedding ring remained stuck halfway down her finger. Jamie's wedding ring was missing. While several people had observed the attacker from a distance, only Jennifer and her neighbour Emery Wilson had seen him up close. Their descriptions were limited as his face had been mostly covered up, but both Jennifer and Emery said the offender was a dark-eyed male of medium build wearing a dark coloured hoodie
他设法用胶带把詹妮弗的双手绑在一起，并试图摘下她的结婚戒指。此时，詹妮弗的尖叫声引起了邻居的注意，导致枪手空手而逃。由于胶带被剪成了两小段，詹妮弗很容易就挣脱了束缚并躲了起来。除了身上有一些轻微的磕碰、淤青和擦伤外，她基本没有受伤。她的结婚戒指仍卡在手指中间。杰米的结婚戒指不见了。虽然有几个人从远处观察到了袭击者，但只有詹妮弗和她的邻居埃默里·威尔逊近距离看到了他。由于他的脸大部分被遮住，他们的描述很有限，但詹妮弗和埃默里都说，袭击者是一名中等身材、深色眼睛的男性，穿着深色连帽衫
and baggy blue jeans. Jennifer believed he was a black man, though Emery couldn't be certain and didn't want to speculate. Multiple 45-calibre bullet casings littered the street around Jamie Faith's body. When the gun was fired, it produced unique imprints on the casings that couldn't be linked to a firearm used in any other known crimes. The pieces of duct tape used to restrain Jennifer were curled up on the driveway near Jamie's body. A matching roll of duct tape was found on the rooftop of the adjacent house, indicating the assailant had tossed it there. No worthwhile forensics were uncovered on any of these items. A quick-thinking local had used their cell phone to capture a photograph of the suspect's vehicle as it fled the scene. It was a black 2004 Nissan Titan pickup truck. Although its license plate
和宽松的蓝色牛仔裤。詹妮弗认为他是一名黑人，但埃默里无法确定，也不想猜测。杰米·费思尸体周围的街道上散落着多个 45 口径的弹壳。当枪支发射时，它在弹壳上留下了独特的印记，这些印记无法与任何其他已知犯罪中使用的枪支联系起来。用于束缚詹妮弗的胶带碎片蜷缩在杰米尸体附近的车道上。在隔壁房子的屋顶上发现了一卷配套的胶带，表明袭击者把它扔到了那里。在这些物品上没有发现任何有价值的法医证据。一位机智的当地人用手机拍下了嫌疑人逃离现场时所驾驶车辆的照片。那是一辆黑色的 2004 年款日产泰坦（Nissan Titan）皮卡车。虽然它的车牌
wasn't visible in the blurry image, a white sticker of the letter T was spotted in the corner of the rear windshield. It appeared to be the emblem of the Texas Rangers baseball team, hinting that the vehicle's owner was local to the state. Witnesses who saw the vehicle flee were struck by how slow it moved, as though the driver wasn't in a hurry. Security camera footage obtained from residences and businesses throughout the area allowed detectives to track the pickup truck in the direct aftermath of the shooting. After leaving South Waverley Drive, the vehicle was filmed driving normally through traffic before entering the Interstate 35 Highway, which stretches northward through multiple US states.
在模糊的图像中看不清楚，但在后挡风玻璃的角落里发现了一个白色的字母“T”贴纸。这似乎是德克萨斯游骑兵队（Texas Rangers）棒球队的标志，暗示车主是该州本地人。目击到车辆逃离的目击者对它行驶速度之慢感到震惊，仿佛司机并不着急。从该地区各处住宅和企业获得的监控录像让侦探们得以追踪到枪击事件发生后皮卡车的去向。在离开南韦弗利大道后，这辆车被拍到在车流中正常行驶，随后进入了 35 号州际公路，这条公路向北延伸，穿过美国多个州。
It vanished from there, its license plate still unclear. Of all the houses along South Waverly Drive that had working exterior cameras, none had captured the shooting or the assailant, only the sounds of gunfire and Jennifer's screaming. The Faiths had several motion sensor cameras on their property, including one at their front door. This camera captured Jennifer just seconds before the confrontation as she exited the house holding Maggie by the leash, with Jamie trailing close behind. The couple had a second camera positioned towards the street, but it wasn't working at the time. They did, however, have a functioning camera that captured part of the neighbouring property's backyard.
它从那里消失了，车牌依然不清楚。在南韦弗利大道上所有安装了室外摄像头的房屋中，没有一家拍到枪击过程或袭击者，只拍到了枪声和詹妮弗的尖叫声。费思夫妇在他们的房产上安装了几个运动传感器摄像头，包括前门的一个。这个摄像头拍到了詹妮弗在对峙发生前几秒钟走出房门，手里牵着玛吉，杰米紧随其后。这对夫妇在朝向街道的方向安装了第二个摄像头，但当时并没有工作。不过，他们确实有一个功能正常的摄像头，拍到了邻居后院的一部分。
Nobody lived in the house, yet five hours before the shooting, at around 2.30am, the Faith's camera recorded a figure moving around the rear of the empty property. The footage was dark and blurry, but the figure appeared to be a man wearing jeans, a dark top and a blue mask. He crept along the side of the house towards the street before disappearing from view. When shown the footage, Jennifer Faith didn't recognise the figure, but she'd heard rumours about a local man who was known to wander around at night whenever he fought with his wife. Investigators were nevertheless suspicious. If the figure was Jamie Faith's killer, it meant he was loitering at the crime scene hours before the
那所房子里没有人住，但在枪击发生前五个小时，即凌晨 2 点 30 分左右，费思家的摄像头记录到一个身影在空房子的后方走动。录像很暗且模糊，但那个身影看起来像是一个穿着牛仔裤、深色上衣和蓝色口罩的男人。他沿着房子侧面朝街道爬行，随后消失在视野中。当看到这段录像时，詹妮弗·费思认不出那个身影，但她听说过当地有一个男人，据说每当他和妻子吵架时，就会在晚上四处游荡。尽管如此，调查人员还是感到怀疑。如果这个身影是杰米·费思的杀手，这意味着他在枪击发生前几个小时就一直在犯罪现场徘徊。
shooting. Given that the Faiths were confronted as they began their morning walk, it seemed as though they were targeted by someone who was familiar with their daily routine. This behaviour didn't correlate with an opportunistic robbery gone wrong. It felt remarkably calculated, like an ambush. An autopsy revealed that Jamie had been shot a total of seven times. He was felled by three initial shots to the chest, then struck thrice more point blank in the head. Notably, the seventh and final shot was aimed at Jamie's groin. The chest wounds were enough to incapacitate Jamie, and the first headshot killed him instantly, which led investigators to question why the killer continued
考虑到费思夫妇是在开始晨间散步时遭到袭击的，他们似乎是被熟悉他们日常作息的人盯上了。这种行为与一次失败的投机性抢劫不符。这感觉非常蓄意，就像一场伏击。尸检显示，杰米总共被射中了七枪。他先是被三枪击中胸部倒地，随后又在近距离被击中头部三次。值得注意的是，第七枪也是最后一枪瞄准了杰米的腹股沟。胸部的伤口足以使杰米丧失行动能力，而第一枪爆头让他当场死亡，这让调查人员质疑为什么凶手还要继续
shooting. This level of overkill was uncharacteristic of a bungled robbery. Each shot was deliberate and accurate, clearly performed by someone who had experience using firearms. The shot to Jamie's groin was highly unusual. Intentional wounds to genitalia typically indicated the attack had sexual connotations. This, coupled with the fact that Jennifer had come away from the deadly encounter relatively unscathed, suggested that her husband was the sole target. Investigators began digging through Jamie Faith's life, looking for anyone who would want to harm him. By all accounts, Jamie was a well-liked and peaceful person who lived a normal life. He enjoyed playing video games, billiards, and bowling, and was a big fan of the Green Bay Packers football team. Those closest to Jamie described him as smart,
射击。这种程度的过度杀戮在一次拙劣的抢劫中是不常见的。每一枪都经过深思熟虑且精准，显然是由有枪支使用经验的人执行的。射向杰米腹股沟的那一枪非常不寻常。对生殖器进行蓄意伤害通常表明袭击具有性暗示。这一点，再加上詹妮弗在致命遭遇中相对毫发无损地逃脱，表明她的丈夫是唯一的目标。调查人员开始挖掘杰米·费思的生活，寻找任何可能想伤害他的人。据各方描述，杰米是一个受人喜爱、爱好和平的人，过着正常的生活。他喜欢玩电子游戏、打台球和保龄球，还是绿湾包装工队（Green Bay Packers）橄榄球队的忠实粉丝。杰米身边的人形容他聪明、
resourceful, quirky, and always happy. With a penchant for button-up Hawaiian shirts and a love for all things wine, food, and travel, Jamie was considered a quintessential easy-going guy. He spent his spare time mentoring at a university where news of his death left his students shattered. Like everyone else, they couldn't imagine why anyone would want to hurt Jamie, let alone kill him. Jamie and Jennifer's marriage was equally praised. As a young man, Jamie told his friends that he was going to remain a lifelong bachelor as he had no interest in marriage or starting a family. That all changed when mutual friends set him up on a blind date with the Jennifer in 2005. Described as two peas in a pod, their attraction was instant
机智、古怪，总是很快乐。杰米偏爱扣领夏威夷衬衫，热爱葡萄酒、美食和旅行，被认为是典型的随和派。他利用业余时间在大学担任导师，他的死讯让他的学生们心碎不已。和所有人一样，他们无法想象为什么会有人想伤害杰米，更不用说杀了他。杰米和詹妮弗的婚姻也同样受到赞誉。年轻时，杰米曾告诉朋友，他打算终身不婚，因为他对结婚或组建家庭没有兴趣。这一切在 2005 年共同的朋友为他安排了一场与詹妮弗的相亲后改变了。他们被形容为“如出一辙”，两人瞬间被对方吸引，
and the pair quickly fell in love. They slotted seamlessly into each other's social circles, with the Jennifer boasting that it was meant to be. In stark contrast to his original life plans, Jamie became a proud provider, devoted husband, and a loving father figure. In the fifteen years of his relationship with the Jennifer, not one person could recall an instance when the pair were in conflict. Their home was always full of love and joy, with the pair hosting weekly game nights with friends and often travelling interstate to visit extended family. Jamie and Jennifer were only ever unashamedly affectionate towards each other,
并迅速坠入爱河。他们无缝地融入了彼此的社交圈，詹妮弗夸耀说这是命中注定。与他最初的人生规划形成鲜明对比的是，杰米成为了一名自豪的供养者、忠诚的丈夫和慈爱的父亲。在与詹妮弗相处的十五年里，没有人能想起他们之间发生过冲突。他们的家总是充满爱与欢乐，两人经常与朋友举办每周游戏之夜，并经常跨州旅行探望远房亲戚。杰米和詹妮弗对彼此总是毫不掩饰地表达爱意，
the type of couple to wear matching outfits when travelling on cruises together. Everyone agreed, the Faiths had the kind of relationship that made them jealous. According to Jennifer, in the lead up to Jamie's death he didn't appear to be afraid or express any concern for his safety. Although she was aware of a recent incident at work that had caused him some distress. Jamie enjoyed his job at American Airlines and was well liked by his co-workers. That made it all the more difficult when he was tasked with laying off 20 of his colleagues due to the COVID-19 pandemic. Jamie struggled to choose which of his team members should go,
是那种一起乘游轮旅行时会穿情侣装的夫妻。每个人都同意，费思夫妇拥有一种让人嫉妒的关系。据詹妮弗说，在杰米去世前夕，他似乎并没有表现出恐惧，也没有表达过任何对自身安全的担忧。尽管她知道最近工作中的一件事让他感到有些苦恼。杰米喜欢他在美国航空公司的工作，也很受同事欢迎。当他因新冠疫情被迫裁掉 20 名同事时，这让他感到更加痛苦。杰米在选择裁掉哪些团队成员时感到挣扎，
as he wanted all of them to stay. The process brought him to tears, but he ultimately went ahead and made the cuts. Investigators spoke to Jamie's superiors. None of them were aware of any disgruntled former employees, but they handed over the names of those who were recently let go. Investigators questioned each individual, but found no indication that any of them blamed to Jamie for losing their jobs, nor did they hold a grudge against him. With no suspects emerging from Jamie's home or work life, investigators expanded their search and came across a promising lead. Prior to meeting Jamie, Jennifer had been married twice before. Both marriages were dysfunctional and short-lived, but it was the first marriage that raised a significant red flag.
因为他希望他们所有人都能留下来。这个过程让他流下了眼泪，但他最终还是执行了裁员。调查人员与杰米的上司进行了交谈。他们中没有人知道有任何不满的前员工，但他们提供了那些最近被解雇的人的名单。调查人员询问了每一个人，但没有发现任何迹象表明他们中有人因为失去工作而责怪杰米，也没有人对他怀恨在心。由于在杰米的家庭或工作生活中没有出现嫌疑人，调查人员扩大了搜索范围，并发现了一条有希望的线索。在遇到杰米之前，詹妮弗曾有过两次婚姻。这两段婚姻都不和谐且短暂，但正是第一段婚姻引起了一个重大的危险信号。
When Jennifer unexpectedly became pregnant in 1996, her husband decided he didn't want a family and abruptly left her before their daughter was born. By the time Jennifer met Jamie, her daughter was eight years old. Jamie wholeheartedly embraced the role of stepfather and illegally adopted Jennifer's daughter when she turned 18. While her biological father had remained a stranger throughout her life, investigators wondered if he harboured animosity towards Jamie for moving in on his family. animosity towards Jamie for moving in on his family. The day before Jamie was killed, he and Jennifer had celebrated the 15th anniversary of the day they first met. The killer stole Jamie's wedding ring and attempted to take Jennifer's too. The rings were worth around $3,000, not enough to
1996 年詹妮弗意外怀孕时，她的丈夫决定不想要家庭，并在女儿出生前突然离开了她。当詹妮弗遇到杰米时，她的女儿已经八岁了。杰米全心全意地接受了继父的角色，并在她 18 岁时合法收养了詹妮弗的女儿。虽然她的亲生父亲一生中一直是个陌生人，但调查人员想知道他是否因为杰米介入了他的家庭而对杰米怀有敌意。在杰米被杀的前一天，他和詹妮弗庆祝了他们初次相遇 15 周年。凶手偷走了杰米的结婚戒指，并试图拿走詹妮弗的。这些戒指价值约 3000 美元，在调查人员看来，这不足以
justify murder as far as investigators were concerned. Therefore, they wondered if the timing wasn't a coincidence. Perhaps taking the rings was meant to be a symbolic act. With nothing to prove this theory, all other possibilities had to be considered. Nothing to prove this theory, all other possibilities had to be considered. The area around South Waverly Drive was being gentrified, with successful career-orientated couples like The Faith seen as harbingers of this change. Investigators wondered whether the attack aimed to ward off further gentrification. Alternatively, what if Jamie had angered a stranger in a road rage incident or something similar and they'd followed him home to confront him? There was also speculation that
成为谋杀的理由。因此，他们怀疑这个时间点并非巧合。也许拿走戒指是一个象征性的行为。由于没有证据证明这一理论，必须考虑所有其他可能性。南韦弗利大道周围的地区正在进行绅士化改造，像费思夫妇这样事业有成的夫妇被视为这种变化的先驱。调查人员想知道这次袭击是否旨在阻止进一步的绅士化。或者，如果杰米在路怒事件或类似的事情中激怒了一个陌生人，而对方跟踪他回家进行对峙呢？还有一种猜测是，
the killer had intended to abduct Jennifer but was forced to abandon his plan when neighbours came to her rescue. Whatever the truth, there was a degree of certainty that the case would resolve itself once the suspect's vehicle was identified. Yet, weeks passed without a breakthrough, despite a $5,000 reward on offer for information. Determined to find her husband's killer, Jennifer Faith started a group text message thread with upwards of 15 of her closest and trusted friends and family. This allowed her to keep messages in one place so that everyone received the latest updates in Jamie's case. She kept them informed about how her and her daughter were coping, while also divulging key information about the investigation that the public wasn't privy to.
凶手原本打算绑架詹妮弗，但当邻居们赶来营救时，他被迫放弃了计划。无论真相如何，人们在一定程度上确信，一旦嫌疑人的车辆被确认，案件就会水落石出。然而，几周过去了，尽管悬赏 5000 美元征集线索，但案件仍无进展。为了找到杀害丈夫的凶手，詹妮弗·费思建立了一个群聊，里面有 15 位她最亲近、最信任的朋友和家人。这让她可以将消息集中在一个地方，以便每个人都能收到杰米案件的最新进展。她让他们了解她和女儿的情况，同时也透露了公众无法获知的调查关键信息。
The group discussed the possibility that Jamie could have been targeted by a serial killer who had been shooting people at random around Dallas. By November 2020, the gunman had carried out multiple attacks over a two-month period, claiming four known victims and injuring many others. He operated from a black Chevy Tahoe, a somewhat similar vehicle to the one used by Jamie's killer. Jennifer presented the theory to the police, but they were unwilling to explore a potential link. Supporters in her group chat criticised detectives for not doing their jobs and for letting Jamie's case fall through the cracks. Jennifer encouraged the group to remain on the lookout for black pick-up trucks and report them to police. She expressed frustration that in
群组成员讨论了杰米可能被一名在达拉斯随机射杀路人的连环杀手盯上的可能性。到 2020 年 11 月，枪手在两个月内实施了多次袭击，造成四名已知受害者死亡，并导致多人受伤。他驾驶的是一辆黑色雪佛兰太浩（Chevy Tahoe），与杰米杀手使用的车辆有些相似。詹妮弗向警方提出了这一理论，但他们不愿探索这种潜在的联系。群聊中的支持者批评侦探们没有做好工作，让杰米的案件被忽视。詹妮弗鼓励群组成员继续留意黑色皮卡车，并向警方报告。她对在
an era where cameras were everywhere, none had clearly captured the license plate of her husband's killer. As the weeks wore on, the mystery persisted and the group chat gradually fell quiet. The general sentiment was that no one was going to be held accountable for Jamie's murder. for Jamie's murder. An emotional Jennifer Faith fronted the media to appeal for help. She voiced her fear that the case was going cold and pleaded with Texans to be on the lookout for the black pickup with the Texas Rangers sticker. The problem was, black pickups were common throughout the state, and the Texas Rangers fanbase stretched far and wide. Furthermore, Jamie's death was just one of 200 homicides reported in Dallas in 2020, and police resources were spread incredibly thin. While Jennifer acknowledged this, she was dismayed by how little information police were
一个到处都是摄像头的时代，竟然没有一个摄像头清晰地拍到丈夫杀手的车牌而感到沮丧。随着时间的推移，谜团依然存在，群聊也逐渐安静下来。普遍的看法是，没有人会为杰米的谋杀负责。情绪激动的詹妮弗·费思面对媒体寻求帮助。她表达了对案件陷入僵局的恐惧，并恳求德克萨斯人留意那辆带有德克萨斯游骑兵队贴纸的黑色皮卡车。问题是，黑色皮卡车在全州都很常见，而且德克萨斯游骑兵队的粉丝群非常广泛。此外，杰米的死亡只是 2020 年达拉斯报告的 200 起凶杀案之一，警力资源极其紧张。虽然詹妮弗承认了这一点，但她对警方提供的关于
giving her regarding the progress of her husband's case. Jennifer begged the community, if you know what happened, I need that foreclosure. I need to make some sense out of this. As for the offender, she said, I just hope that at some point this person can recognise the gravity of what they've done and what they've taken from myself and my daughter and feel some sort of guilt enough to come forward. We just really need some answers. With the killer on the loose, the local community lived in fear that he would strike again. Residents of South Waverly Drive were reluctant to venture outside, and those who did were constantly looking over their shoulder. Jennifer admitted to her loved ones that she was struggling to sleep.
丈夫案件进展的信息之少感到沮丧。詹妮弗恳求社区：“如果你知道发生了什么，我需要那个真相。我需要弄清楚这一切。”至于凶手，她说：“我只是希望在某个时候，这个人能意识到他们所做之事的严重性，意识到他们从我和我女儿身边夺走了什么，并感到某种程度的内疚，从而站出来。我们真的需要一些答案。”由于凶手逍遥法外，当地社区生活在恐惧中，担心他会再次作案。南韦弗利大道的居民不愿外出，即使外出的人也总是回头张望。詹妮弗向亲人承认，她难以入睡。
Sometimes she broke down in inconsolable sobbing fits, other times she was an emotional blank slate saying she didn't feel anything at all. One of the hardest things for Jennifer was that she still had to walk her dog, Maggie, which was something she only ever did with Jamie. She confided in others that she was terrified of going out alone in case Jamie's killer was waiting to finish the job. Neighbours pushed their own apprehension aside to walk with the Jennifer in a group. They were on edge the entire time, constantly scanning the road in all directions for the black pick-up truck. The rest of the community also rallied together,
有时她会陷入无法安慰的啜泣中，有时她又像一张情感白纸，说她什么感觉都没有。对詹妮弗来说，最困难的事情之一是她仍然必须遛狗玛吉，这是她以前只和杰米一起做的事情。她向别人吐露，她害怕独自外出，以防杰米的杀手还在等着完成任务。邻居们抛开自己的忧虑，结伴陪詹妮弗散步。他们全程都处于紧张状态，不断向各个方向扫描路上的黑色皮卡车。社区的其他成员也团结起来，
with over 50 families participating in a meal train to provide Jennifer and her daughter with food each day. Jamie had been the breadwinner of the family at the time of his death, as Jennifer had taken a break from work during the pandemic. Recognising the financial struggles she faced, a friend of Jennifer's gave her a $5,000 check to help pay for daily expenses. Another supporter organised an online fundraiser for Jamie's funeral, which raised over $60,000 in less than a week. Jennifer expressed her gratitude by organising two memorial services for Jamie, one locally and another in Arizona where they'd first met. It was also where Jamie had spent over
有超过 50 个家庭参与了送餐计划，每天为詹妮弗和她的女儿提供食物。杰米在去世时是家里的经济支柱，因为詹妮弗在疫情期间暂停了工作。意识到她面临的经济困难，詹妮弗的一位朋友给了她一张 5000 美元的支票，以帮助支付日常开支。另一位支持者为杰米的葬礼组织了一场在线筹款活动，在不到一周的时间内筹集了超过 6 万美元。詹妮弗通过为杰米组织两场追悼会表达了她的感激之情，一场在当地，另一场在他们初次相遇的亚利桑那州。这也是杰米度过了
20 years of his life until a job promotion led him to relocate his family to Texas. The two services allowed Jennifer to grieve with friends, old and new, while eulogising the loss of the man she called the backbone of her family. When Thanksgiving passed in November, Jennifer spoke of how gut-wrenching it was to look at the empty dining chair where Jamie typically sat. She told a reporter for Fox 4, All I know is Jamie was my best friend and the best husband and father anyone could ask for. It's been horrible. I teed her between completely heartbroken and completely devastated every day.
20 多年生活的地方，直到一次工作晋升促使他将家人搬到了德克萨斯州。这两场追悼会让詹妮弗能够与新老朋友一起哀悼，同时缅怀她称之为家庭支柱的那个男人。当 11 月感恩节过去时，詹妮弗谈到看着杰米平时坐的空餐椅是多么令人心碎。她告诉福克斯 4 台（Fox 4）的记者：“我只知道杰米是我最好的朋友，也是任何人所能要求的最好的丈夫和父亲。这太可怕了。我每天都在彻底心碎和彻底崩溃之间徘徊。”
Homicide detectives checked in on Jennifer often and sometimes joined her in prayer, but they also had something uncomfortable to address. Hours after Janie was killed, they had asked Jennifer if she would consent to having her cell phone examined. They explained this was just a formality to ensure they conducted a fair investigation across the board and clarified that Jennifer wasn't being considered a suspect. Jennifer was initially hesitant to hand over her phone, but she ultimately agreed to do so. On it, investigators found text messages sent between Jennifer and a close friend of hers named Tina Sprang.
凶杀案侦探经常查看詹妮弗的情况，有时还会和她一起祈祷，但他们也有一些令人不安的事情需要处理。在杰米被杀几个小时后，他们曾询问詹妮弗是否同意检查她的手机。他们解释说这只是为了确保全面开展公平调查的例行公事，并澄清詹妮弗并未被视为嫌疑人。詹妮弗起初对交出手机感到犹豫，但最终还是同意了。在手机里，调查人员发现了詹妮弗和她的一位名叫蒂娜·斯普朗（Tina Sprang）的密友之间发送的短信。
The pair kept one another updated about what was going on in their lives, nothing of which was particularly noteworthy. That was until investigators scrolled back in the women's text history to Monday April 20, 2020, six months before Jamie was gunned down. April 20, 2020, six months before Jamie was gunned down. That day, Jennifer sent Tina a string of texts that began. So, I have no idea when I am going to be able to talk to you over the phone, but I am pretty much having a fullown emotional affair. Casefile will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors.
两人互相更新各自的生活动态，其中没有什么特别值得注意的内容。直到调查人员翻回到这两位女性 2020 年 4 月 20 日（杰米被枪杀前六个月）的短信记录。那天，詹妮弗给蒂娜发了一连串短信，开头写道：“所以，我不知道什么时候能和你通电话，但我基本上正在经历一场全面的情感出轨。”Casefile 稍后回来。感谢您通过收听本期节目的赞助商来支持我们。
Let's face it, after a night with the drinks, it can be hard to bounce back the next day. I know I don't bounce back like I used to. So for me it becomes a choice between having a great night or a great next day. That is until I found Z-Biotics Pre-Alcohol. Pre-Alcohol is the world's first genetically engineered probiotic. It was invented by PhD scientists to tackle rough mornings after drinking. Here's how it works. When you drink, alcohol gets converted into a toxic byproduct in the gut. It's this byproduct, not dehydration, that's to blame for your rough next day.
面对现实吧，喝了一晚酒之后，第二天很难恢复状态。我知道我再也回不到以前那种状态了。所以对我来说，这变成了在享受一个美好的夜晚和拥有一个美好的第二天之间做选择。直到我发现了 Z-Biotics Pre-Alcohol。Pre-Alcohol 是世界上第一款基因工程益生菌。它是由博士科学家发明的，旨在解决饮酒后难受的早晨。它是这样工作的：当你喝酒时，酒精会在肠道中转化为一种有毒的副产品。正是这种副产品，而不是脱水，导致了你第二天的不适。
Pre-alcohol produces an enzyme to break this byproduct down. Just remember to make Z-Biotics your first drink of the night, drink responsibly, and you'll feel your best tomorrow. Olivia LaVoice, host of the Casefile Presents series The Bakersfield 3, uses Z-Biotics pre-alcohol before a night out. With pre-alcohol before a night out. With pre-alcohol, Olivia knows she will feel good the next morning and can confidently plan her next day activities, including working on her next Casefile Presents release. Pre-alcohol is for responsible adults, so always drink responsibly, pace yourself, hydrate
Pre-alcohol 产生一种酶来分解这种副产品。只要记得把 Z-Biotics 作为你当晚的第一杯酒，负责任地饮酒，你明天就会感觉最好。Casefile Presents 系列《贝克斯菲尔德 3》（The Bakersfield 3）的主持人奥利维亚·拉沃伊斯（Olivia LaVoice）在晚上外出前会使用 Z-Biotics Pre-Alcohol。有了 Pre-Alcohol，奥利维亚知道她第二天早上会感觉良好，并且可以自信地计划她第二天的活动，包括制作她的下一个 Casefile Presents 节目。Pre-Alcohol 适合负责任的成年人，所以请务必负责任地饮酒，控制节奏，补充水分，
and get a good night's sleep. Vacations, weddings, birthdays and reunions. There's so much going on. Get the most out of your summer plans by stocking up on pre-alcohol now. Go to zbiotics.com slash case file to get 15% off your first order when you use Casefile at checkout. Pre-alcohol is backed with 100% money back guarantee, so if you're unsatisfied for any reason, they'll refund your money, no questions asked. Remember to head to zbiotics.com slash Casefile and use the code CASEFILE at checkout for 15% off. Thank you ZBiotics for sponsoring this episode and our good times. Starting investing can feel pretty intimidating. Most people don't know where to start and think they need a lot of money. Busy schedules leave a little time for research and saving for retirement can seem so far
并睡个好觉。假期、婚礼、生日和聚会。事情太多了。现在就囤积 Pre-Alcohol，充分利用你的暑期计划。访问 zbiotics.com/casefile，在结账时使用 Casefile，首单可享 15% 的折扣。Pre-Alcohol 提供 100% 退款保证，所以如果你因任何原因不满意，他们会退还你的钱，不问任何问题。记得前往 zbiotics.com/casefile，并在结账时使用代码 CASEFILE 以获得 15% 的折扣。感谢 ZBiotics 赞助本期节目和我们的美好时光。开始投资可能会让人感到相当畏惧。大多数人不知道从哪里开始，认为他们需要很多钱。繁忙的日程安排几乎没有时间进行研究，而为退休储蓄似乎还很遥远，
off it's hard to even get started. I felt the same way when I first looked into investing. The sheer amount of information and fear of making mistakes held me back for years. But that's where Acorns comes in. Acorns makes it easy to start automatically saving and investing for you, your kids, and your retirement. You don't need a lot of money or expertise to invest with Acorns. In fact, you can get started with just your spare change.
以至于很难开始。当我第一次研究投资时，我也感觉一样。海量的信息和对犯错的恐惧让我退缩了多年。但这就是 Acorns 的用武之地。Acorns 让你可以轻松地自动为自己、孩子和退休进行储蓄和投资。你不需要大量的资金或专业知识就可以通过 Acorns 进行投资。事实上，你只需用零钱就可以开始。
Acorns recommends an expert-built portfolio that fits you and your money goals, then automatically invests your money for you. And now, Acorns is putting their money into your future. Open an Acorns Leda IRA and get up to a 3% match on new contributions. That's extra money for your retirement. With Acorns, you can feel more secure about your financial goals, even with a busy schedule. Head to acorns.com slash case file or download the Acorns app to start saving and investing for your future today. Paid non-client endorsement compensation provides incentive to positively promote Acorns. Investing involves risk.
Acorns 推荐适合你和你的财务目标的专家构建的投资组合，然后自动为你投资。现在，Acorns 正在将他们的资金投入到你的未来中。开设一个 Acorns Later IRA 账户，新缴款可获得高达 3% 的匹配。那是为你退休准备的额外资金。有了 Acorns，即使日程繁忙，你也能对自己的财务目标感到更安全。前往 acorns.com/casefile 或下载 Acorns 应用程序，立即开始为你的未来储蓄和投资。付费非客户代言补偿提供了积极推广 Acorns 的激励。投资涉及风险。
Acorns Advisors LLC and SEC Registered Investment Advisor. View important disclosures at acorns.com slash Casefile. Thank you for listening to this episode's ads. By supporting our sponsors, you support Casefile to continue to deliver quality content. Jennifer Faith revealed to her friend Tina that the person she was having an emotional affair with was a man named Darren Lopez. The two had dated in high school 30 years prior and amicably broke up during their first year of college when Darren was deployed overseas with the military.
Acorns Advisors LLC 是一家美国证券交易委员会（SEC）注册的投资顾问。请在 acorns.com/casefile 查看重要披露信息。感谢您收听本期节目的广告。通过支持我们的赞助商，您支持 Casefile 继续提供高质量的内容。詹妮弗·费思向她的朋友蒂娜透露，她发生情感出轨的对象是一个名叫达伦·洛佩兹（Darren Lopez）的男人。两人在 30 年前的高中时期曾约会过，并在大学一年级时和平分手，当时达伦被派往海外服兵役。
He went on to join the Special Forces but had since retired and was living in Tennessee. He'd reached out to Jennifer online a month earlier, and although they hadn't yet met up in person, they texted all day, every day, and spoke on the phone too. Jennifer admitted to Tina that the whole situation was crazy and stupid. She said that Jamie knew about the affair, and he was scared and sad. She justified her actions by divulging that she and Jamie hadn't been intimate in four years despite her efforts to initiate. She felt like they loved each other but weren't in love with each other.
他后来加入了特种部队，但此后已经退役，住在田纳西州。他一个月前在网上联系了詹妮弗，虽然他们还没有亲自见面，但他们每天都在发短信，也经常通电话。詹妮弗向蒂娜承认，整个情况既疯狂又愚蠢。她说杰米知道这段婚外情，他感到害怕和难过。她为自己的行为辩解说，尽管她努力主动，但她和杰米已经四年没有亲密行为了。她觉得他们彼此相爱，但并不是那种热恋中的爱。
There was no passion between them anymore and the only romantic thing Jamie did was give her hugs. Jennifer admitted, I don't feel wanted by him at all other than to be his partner. Despite these issues, Jennifer said that Jamie was a good man and father, and she'd been prepared to stay with him for the rest of her life as they made a great parenting team. It was only when Darren reappeared on the scene that she started questioning things. Jennifer confessed to Tina, The emotions and the connection, I feel like I am being torn in two.
他们之间不再有激情，杰米唯一浪漫的行为就是给她拥抱。詹妮弗承认：“除了做他的伴侣，我根本感觉不到他想要我。”尽管存在这些问题，詹妮弗说杰米是一个好男人和好父亲，她曾准备和他共度余生，因为他们是一个很棒的育儿团队。直到达伦重新出现，她才开始质疑一切。詹妮弗向蒂娜坦白：“那种情感和联系，我觉得自己快要被撕裂成两半了。”
Tina gave her credit for being up front with Jamie and not going behind his back. Jennifer revealed that Darren had devised a five-year plan that would enable them to start a new life together. While she wasn't going to make any moves or do anything rash any time soon, she admitted, "...but I'm not going to stop talking to Darren either. When Jennifer was first interviewed by detectives after Jamie's murder, she had alluded to there being some intimacy problems in her marriage but maintained it was otherwise perfect. She made no mention of her relationship with Darren and no one else in her life seemed to be aware of it either. When police checked Jennifer's cell phone, there were no calls or texts from Darren. They wondered if she had deleted the evidence of her infidelity in anticipation of her phone
蒂娜称赞她对杰米坦诚，没有背着他做这些事。詹妮弗透露，达伦制定了一个五年计划，让他们能够开始新的生活。虽然她近期不会采取任何行动或做任何鲁莽的事，但她承认：“……但我也不会停止和达伦说话。”当杰米被谋杀后，詹妮弗第一次接受侦探采访时，她曾提到婚姻中存在一些亲密关系问题，但坚称除此之外一切都很完美。她没有提到她与达伦的关系，她生活中的其他人似乎也不知道这件事。当警方检查詹妮弗的手机时，没有发现达伦的通话或短信。他们怀疑她删除了不忠的证据，以防手机
being searched while forgetting about the interaction she'd had with Tina Sprang back in April. There was also the possibility that she didn't mention the emotional affair because it had fizzled out entirely. Two months before Jamie's murder, Tina had texted Jennifer, you still talking to that guy? Jennifer responded, I put the brakes on with him. While she admitted she still had strong emotions for Darren and it had been a hard decision, she said, Jamie was so hurt and internalizing everything, and she couldn't do it to him.
被搜查，却忘记了她在 4 月份与蒂娜·斯普朗的互动。还有一种可能性是，她没有提到这段情感出轨是因为它已经完全平息了。在杰米被谋杀前两个月，蒂娜曾给詹妮弗发短信：“你还在和那个男人说话吗？”詹妮弗回答说：“我和他踩了刹车。”虽然她承认她对达伦仍有强烈的感情，这是一个艰难的决定，但她说：“杰米太受伤了，把一切都憋在心里，我不能对他这样做。”
Although Jennifer didn't have any communication history with Darren on her phone, she did have his name, number, email, and residential address in her list of contacts. Darren Lopez lived in the unincorporated community of Cumberland Furnace in northern Tennessee, 650 miles east of Jennifer's home. A police check revealed that 48-year-old Darren had no history with law enforcement. However, registered under his name was a black 2004 Nissan Titan pickup truck. Police in Texas reached out to their Tennessee counterparts who agreed to drive by Darren Lopez's property on the lookout for the pickup truck. Darren lived on a 20-acre ranch on an isolated rural stretch defined by forest and farmland.
虽然詹妮弗的手机上没有任何与达伦的通讯记录，但她的联系人列表中确实有他的名字、电话号码、电子邮件和居住地址。达伦·洛佩兹住在田纳西州北部坎伯兰熔炉（Cumberland Furnace）的非建制社区，距离詹妮弗家以东 650 英里。警方调查显示，48 岁的达伦没有犯罪记录。然而，以他的名义注册了一辆黑色的 2004 年款日产泰坦皮卡车。德克萨斯州的警方联系了田纳西州的同行，他们同意开车经过达伦·洛佩兹的房产，寻找那辆皮卡车。达伦住在一个 20 英亩的牧场上，位于一片被森林和农田环绕的偏远乡村地带。
His house wasn't visible from the street, so a police helicopter was dispatched to conduct aerial surveillance. The view from overhead revealed that the property featured various outbuildings, including a barn and several sheds. A couple of horses were gathered around a modest farmhouse where a black pick-up truck was parked, a white sticker of the letter T visible on its rear windshield. Detectives realised they'd been mistaken. They had assumed Jamie Faith's killer was a Texan after misidentifying the T-sticker on his car for the emblem of the Texas Rangers baseball team. It was in fact a similarly designed logo for the University of Tennessee.
他的房子从街上看不见，所以警方派出一架直升机进行空中监视。从上方俯瞰，可以看到该房产有各种附属建筑，包括一个谷仓和几个棚屋。几匹马聚集在一座简朴的农舍周围，那里停着一辆黑色皮卡车，后挡风玻璃上贴着一个白色的字母T贴纸。侦探们意识到他们搞错了。他们曾误以为杰米·费斯的凶手是德州人，因为他们把车上的T型贴纸误认为是德州游骑兵棒球队的标志。事实上，那是一个设计相似的田纳西大学标志。
Investigators unearthed what they could about Darren Lopez and learnt that he and Jennifer had indeed attended high school in Arizona together before going to the same college. Darren joined the military within a year and went on to become a medic in the special forces, where he was specially trained to keep a critically injured casualty alive on his own for seven days. to keep a critically injured casualty alive on his own for seven days. Darin had been deployed overseas multiple times, including to active war zones in the Middle East. He was known for being compassionate towards the locals in these areas, checking in on them and offering his help while tending to their wounds and playing with their children. In 2005, Darren was in Iraq travelling in a Humvee when it was blown up by a roadside improvised explosive device. The blast knocked
调查人员挖掘了关于达伦·洛佩兹的一切信息，得知他和詹妮弗确实在亚利桑那州上过同一所高中，后来又去了同一所大学。达伦在一年内加入了军队，并成为特种部队的一名医务兵，在那里他接受了专门训练，能够独自维持一名受重伤的伤员七天的生命。达伦曾多次被派往海外，包括中东的活跃战区。他以对这些地区的当地人富有同情心而闻名，他会探望他们，在为他们处理伤口和与他们的孩子玩耍时提供帮助。2005年，达伦在伊拉克乘坐悍马车时，被路边的简易爆炸装置炸毁。爆炸将
Darren unconscious. When he came to, he searched the vehicle's remains for survivors. He pulled out a fellow soldier who had stopped breathing and provided aid that saved the man's life. They, along with two other soldiers, were the only survivors. Nineteen others were killed. Aside from the concussion, one of Darren's eardrums was blown out, but that appeared to be the worst of his injuries. As a medic, Darren was fundamental to his 12-man squad, and without him they would all be pulled from duty.
达伦震昏了。当他醒来时，他在车辆残骸中寻找幸存者。他拉出了一名已经停止呼吸的战友，并提供了挽救该男子生命的救助。他们和另外两名士兵是唯一的幸存者。其他十九人丧生。除了脑震荡，达伦的一只耳膜被震破，但这似乎是他最严重的伤势。作为一名医务兵，达伦对他所在的12人小队至关重要，没有他，他们都会被撤职。
He spent just five days recovering before being sent back into operation. It took another five years before Darren Lopez was diagnosed with a traumatic brain injury as a direct result of the Humvee Blast, along with post-traumatic stress disorder. He was deployed once more before higher-ups ruled him out of combat entirely. After 26 years of service, he was discharged as a decorated and respected soldier, having earned a Purple Heart and two Bronze Star medals for his heroic achievements. By 2020, Darren had separated from his wife of 23 years with whom he had five daughters, two of which were stepchildren. He was living off disability and social security
他只用了五天时间恢复就重新投入行动。又过了五年，达伦·洛佩兹才被诊断出患有直接由悍马爆炸引起的创伤性脑损伤，以及创伤后应激障碍。在被上级完全排除在战斗任务之外前，他又被部署了一次。在服役26年后，他以一名功勋卓著且受人尊敬的士兵身份退伍，因其英勇表现获得了紫心勋章和两枚铜星勋章。到2020年，达伦与结婚23年的妻子分居，他们育有五个女儿，其中两个是继女。他靠残疾补助金和社会保障
payments as he was unable to adjust to civilian employment. Even though there was nothing to indicate Darren was a danger to society, detectives were aware that he was trained to kill. Jennifer Faith had told her friend Tina Sprang she had to put the brakes on her emotional affair with Darren to recommit to Jamie. This led investigators to consider whether Darren could have been fuelled by rejection, jealousy, or revenge and had decided to murder her husband. Maybe he hoped that by getting Jamie out of the picture, he could have Jennifer all to himself. While it was a solid theory, investigators had no proof. They decided to keep their suspicions under wraps as they gathered further evidence. Although Darren didn't appear to be a threat,
金生活，因为他无法适应平民工作。尽管没有任何迹象表明达伦对社会构成威胁，但侦探们知道他受过杀人训练。詹妮弗·费斯曾告诉她的朋友蒂娜·斯普朗，她必须停止与达伦的婚外情，以重新致力于杰米。这促使调查人员考虑达伦是否可能因被拒绝、嫉妒或复仇而决定谋杀她的丈夫。也许他希望通过除掉杰米，就能独占詹妮弗。虽然这是一个可靠的理论，但调查人员没有证据。他们决定在收集更多证据的同时对怀疑保密。虽然达伦看起来不像是一个威胁，
he was placed under 24-hour covert surveillance. Cameras were hidden in the trees around his home while undercover officers tailed him in unmarked vehicles whenever he left the property. Officers mentioned nothing about Darren to Jennifer Faith. Now that they knew she was keeping secrets, she couldn't be trusted. She couldn't be trusted. Jennifer's cell phone had since been returned to her and she was asked to voluntarily resubmit it for further analysis. She was once again reluctant but eventually hand delivered it to the police station. Investigators hoped a data extraction would reveal communications she might have had with Darren Lopez, as it could recover deleted call logs, texts, videos, photos, files, and emails.
但他被置于24小时秘密监视之下。摄像机被隐藏在他家周围的树木中，每当他离开房产时，便衣警察就会驾驶无标记车辆跟踪他。警察没有向詹妮弗·费斯提及任何关于达伦的事情。既然他们知道她在隐瞒秘密，她就不可信了。她不可信了。詹妮弗的手机此后已归还给她，并被要求自愿重新提交以进行进一步分析。她再次表现出不情愿，但最终还是亲自将其送到了警察局。调查人员希望数据提取能揭示她可能与达伦·洛佩兹进行的交流，因为这可以恢复已删除的通话记录、短信、视频、照片、文件和电子邮件。
If nothing else, it would confirm whether content had been deleted, even if it couldn't be fully restored. But the data extraction revealed absolutely nothing. This meant the device had been wiped clean with a factory reset, a process that restored the phone to the same condition as when it was first purchased. In the meantime, investigators had noticed that the T-sticker on the back of Darren Lopez's truck had disappeared. Darren had also added a different white decal to the left side of the tailgate, as if attempting to change his truck's appearance. Still, he didn't meet up with Jennifer or do anything to incriminate himself in Jamie Faith's murder. He just carried
如果什么都没有，至少可以确认内容是否已被删除，即使无法完全恢复。但数据提取结果显示什么都没有。这意味着设备已被恢复出厂设置彻底清除，这一过程将手机恢复到了刚购买时的状态。与此同时，调查人员注意到达伦·洛佩兹卡车后部的T型贴纸已经消失了。达伦还在后挡板左侧添加了另一个白色贴花，似乎试图改变他卡车的外观。尽管如此，他并没有与詹妮弗见面，也没有做任何会让他卷入杰米·费斯谋杀案的事情。他只是照常
on his life as normal. It occurred to investigators that if Darren had no reason to believe he was being viewed with suspicion, then he had no reason to conceal evidence. It was therefore possible that his cell phone still contained the extensive history of communication with the Jennifer Faith they were looking for. There was no legal way to search the device directly without alerting Darren, at which point he could swiftly perform a factory reset. So investigators took a different approach. In January 2021, four months after Jamie Faith's murder, they obtained records from Darren's cellular service provider, which showed a history of all incoming and outgoing calls and texts on his device.
过着他的生活。调查人员想到，如果达伦没有理由认为自己受到怀疑，那么他就没有理由隐瞒证据。因此，他的手机里很可能仍然包含他们正在寻找的与詹妮弗·费斯的大量通信记录。在不惊动达伦的情况下，没有合法途径直接搜索该设备，因为一旦惊动，他可以迅速执行恢复出厂设置。因此，调查人员采取了不同的方法。2021年1月，即杰米·费斯被谋杀四个月后，他们从达伦的移动服务提供商那里获得了记录，显示了他设备上所有来电和去电以及短信的历史记录。
While the provider had no way of uncovering what was said in these interactions, they could ascertain who initiated contact, when, where, and for how long? Astoundingly, in the 10 months between March 2020 and January 2021, Darren Lopez's cell phone had been in contact with the Jennifer Faith cell phone over 280,000 times. The pair typically sent each other upwards of 500 texts a day. In October, the month Jamie was killed, Darren and Jennifer had contacted each other more than 13,000 times. The longest they went without interacting was 10 hours, except for in one instance. From 1.07pm on Thursday October 8, 2020, and 5.18pm on Friday October 9 2020, there was no contact between the two phones for 28 hours. This just so happened to be the time period in which Jamie Faith was murdered. This information coupled with records pulled from cell towers, GPS data, Wi-Fi access points
虽然提供商无法查明这些互动中说了什么，但他们可以确定是谁发起的联系、何时、何地以及持续了多久。令人震惊的是，在2020年3月至2021年1月这10个月间，达伦·洛佩兹的手机与詹妮弗·费斯的手机联系了超过28万次。两人通常每天互发500多条短信。在杰米被杀的10月份，达伦和詹妮弗联系了超过13000次。他们之间最长的互动间隔是10小时，只有一次例外。从2020年10月8日星期四下午1点07分到2020年10月9日星期五下午5点18分，两部手机之间有28小时没有任何联系。这恰好是杰米·费斯被谋杀的时间段。这些信息加上从手机信号塔、GPS数据、Wi-Fi接入点提取的记录
and Bluetooth beacons, enabled investigators to piece together a timeline of events. On the afternoon of Thursday October 8, 2020, the day before Jamie was killed, Darren's cell was tracked to his Tennessee home. By 1pm, he and Jennifer had messaged each other 133 times. At 1.07, Darren received a text from Jennifer marking their final interaction. 20 minutes later, Darren's device was on the move. It pinged off of various cell towers, leaving breadcrumbs for investigators to follow. Around this same time, Darren's phone was used to search online for directions to the Faith's residence, which was a 10-hour drive away. Darren's cell moved south until 1.51pm when it stopped at a gas station.
和蓝牙信标，使调查人员能够拼凑出事件的时间线。2020年10月8日星期四下午，即杰米被杀的前一天，达伦的手机被追踪到他在田纳西州的家中。到下午1点，他和詹妮弗已经互发了133条信息。1点07分，达伦收到了詹妮弗的一条短信，标志着他们最后的互动。20分钟后，达伦的设备开始移动。它连接了不同的手机信号塔，为调查人员留下了追踪的线索。大约在同一时间，达伦的手机被用来在线搜索前往费斯住所的路线，那有10小时的车程。达伦的手机向南移动，直到下午1点51分在一家加油站停下。
CCTV footage captured Darren Lopez as he pumped gas into his black pickup truck, the white T sticker visible on its rear windshield. He then entered the gas station wearing a blue face mask over his nose and mouth. A sales receipt confirmed that Darren had purchased the fuel, a DVD and some snacks using cash, preventing the record of this sale from appearing in his bank account. The CCTV footage was a major find because it established that Darren was travelling alone in his truck with his cell phone, eliminating the possibility that someone else was using his vehicle or phone that day. At 2.19pm, Darren was tracked to driving west until he crossed the border into the state
监控录像拍到了达伦·洛佩兹为他的黑色皮卡车加油，后挡风玻璃上清晰可见白色的T型贴纸。然后他戴着蓝色口罩遮住口鼻进入加油站。销售收据证实，达伦使用现金购买了燃料、一张DVD和一些零食，防止了这笔交易的记录出现在他的银行账户中。监控录像是一个重大发现，因为它确定了达伦当天独自驾驶他的卡车并携带手机，排除了当天有其他人使用他的车辆或手机的可能性。下午2点19分，达伦被追踪到向西行驶，直到他越过边界进入
of Arkansas. He travelled along Interstate 40, which leads to Interstate 30 and into Texas. From 6pm, Darren's device was no longer traceable. It seemed he knew that he could be traced via his phone and had the foresight to turn it off before reaching Texas. before reaching Texas. In a bizarre move that left investigators utterly perplexed, Darren turned his device back on at 1.47am. It immediately pinpointed his location as Dallas, Texas. Again, he used the internet to search for directions to the Faiths' residence on South Waverley Drive.
阿肯色州。他沿着40号州际公路行驶，该公路通往30号州际公路并进入德克萨斯州。从下午6点开始，达伦的设备就无法追踪了。他似乎知道自己可以通过手机被追踪，并有先见之明在到达德克萨斯州之前将其关闭。在到达德克萨斯州之前。在一个让调查人员完全困惑的奇怪举动中，达伦在凌晨1点47分重新打开了设备。它立即定位到他在德克萨斯州达拉斯。同样，他使用互联网搜索前往南韦弗利大道费斯住所的路线。
He drove past their house at 2.18am before becoming untraceable again. The shadowy figure loitering at the vacant property next door to the Faith's was captured on security footage 10 minutes later. Their outfit and the shape of their body matched Darren Lopez to a tee, right down to the blue mask. When Jamie Faith was killed five hours later at 7.30am, witnesses described the assailant as fitting Darren's description. For the next nine hours, Darren's cell phone remained untraceable. Then, at 5pm, he turned the device on and was geo-located at the same gas station back in Tennessee where he once again paid for his purchases with cash. He also texted Jennifer Faith for the first time in 28 hours. faith for the first time in 28 hours. The pair messaged back and forth approximately 50 times until Darren arrived home shortly after 6pm where they continued texting and also spoke on the phone
他在凌晨2点18分开车经过他们的房子，然后再次变得无法追踪。10分钟后，监控录像拍到了在费斯家隔壁空置房产徘徊的黑影。他们的装束和体型与达伦·洛佩兹完全吻合，甚至连蓝色口罩都一样。五小时后，即早上7点30分，当杰米·费斯被杀时，目击者描述袭击者符合达伦的特征。在接下来的九个小时里，达伦的手机一直无法追踪。然后，在下午5点，他打开了设备，被定位在田纳西州回来的同一个加油站，在那里他再次用现金支付了购买费用。他还给詹妮弗·费斯发了28小时以来的第一条短信。这是28小时以来第一次给詹妮弗·费斯发短信。两人来回发了大约50条信息，直到达伦在下午6点后不久回到家，在那里他们继续发短信，并且还通了两次电话
twice before the day was through. From that point on, Darren and Jennifer continued to contact each other hundreds of times a day. It was evident that Jennifer had cleared her phone of these interactions before submitting it to the police. What the pair discussed during their lengthy affair remained a mystery, but investigators time to make their move and find out. Casefile will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors. We all dread the what should we have for dinner question. I know I do. Coming up with new and interesting recipe ideas is time consuming,
在那一天结束之前。从那时起，达伦和詹妮弗继续每天联系数百次。很明显，詹妮弗在将手机交给警察之前已经清除了这些互动记录。两人在漫长的婚外情期间讨论了什么仍然是个谜，但调查人员有时间采取行动并找出答案。Casefile节目稍后回来。感谢您通过收听本集赞助商来支持我们。我们都害怕“晚餐吃什么”这个问题。我知道我怕。想出新的、有趣的食谱创意很耗时，
while ordering takeout is never really satisfying and always leads to spending too much money. So if you'd rather enjoy a home-cooked meal without the stress of planning ahead, Home Chef makes it really easy and also saves you money. Home Chef provides fresh ingredients and chef designed recipes conveniently delivered to your doorstep to simplify your cooking experience. And they've got meal kits for every kind of cook. There are classic kits with pre-portioned ingredients and easy instructions, oven-ready kits with pre-chopped ingredients, and quicker microwave meals that assemble in minutes. Home Chef has over 30 options a week and serves a variety of dietary needs.
而点外卖从来都不真正令人满意，而且总是导致花费太多钱。所以，如果您想在没有提前计划压力的情况下享受一顿家常饭菜，Home Chef让这一切变得非常简单，而且还能为您省钱。Home Chef提供新鲜食材和厨师设计的食谱，方便地送到您家门口，以简化您的烹饪体验。他们为各种厨师提供了餐包。有配有预分量食材和简单说明的经典餐包，有配有预切食材的烤箱即食餐包，还有几分钟内即可组装完成的更快的微波炉餐。Home Chef每周有超过30种选择，满足各种饮食需求。
They even have a delicious kid-friendly family menu with 18 new options each week which is picky eater approved and takes the stress out of dinnertime. Not only is Home Chef convenient, it's economical too. Their customers save an average of $86 per month on groceries. Olivia LaVoice, host of Casefile Presents series The Bakersfield 3 is loving Home Chef for its convenience and the high quality of the ingredients supplied. She says it's also introduced her to new recipes she wouldn't have otherwise made. For a limited time, Home Chef is offering our listeners 18 free meals plus free dessert for
他们甚至有美味的儿童友好型家庭菜单，每周有18种新选择，这些选择得到了挑食者的认可，消除了晚餐时间的压力。Home Chef不仅方便，而且经济。他们的客户平均每月在杂货上节省86美元。Casefile Presents系列《贝克斯菲尔德3》的主持人奥利维亚·拉沃伊斯非常喜欢Home Chef的便利性和所提供食材的高质量。她说，它还向她介绍了她以前不会制作的新食谱。在有限的时间内，Home Chef为我们的听众提供18顿免费餐点，外加终身免费甜点，
life and of course free shipping on your first box. Go to homeeshef.com slash casefile. That's homeshef.com slash casefile for 18 free meals and free dessert for life. You heard that right. Homeshef.com slash casefile. Must be an active subscriber to receive free dessert. Thank you for listening to this episode's ads. By supporting our sponsors, you support Casefile to continue to deliver quality content. Police knew that arresting Darren Lopez was fraught with risk. His background with special forces meant he was an elite trained killer. If the arrest was handled poorly, police feared Darren might feel like he had nothing left to lose and do something drastic. He might have used his knowledge of warfare to booby trap his home or prepare for a siege. The decision was therefore made to
当然还有首单免费送货。请访问homechef.com斜杠casefile。即homeshef.com斜杠casefile，可获得18顿免费餐点和终身免费甜点。您没听错。Homeshef.com斜杠casefile。必须是活跃订阅者才能获得免费甜点。感谢您收听本集的广告。通过支持我们的赞助商，您支持Casefile继续提供优质内容。警方知道逮捕达伦·洛佩兹充满了风险。他在特种部队的背景意味着他是一名精英训练的杀手。如果逮捕行动处理不当，警方担心达伦可能会觉得他已一无所有，从而做出激进的事情。他可能利用他的战争知识在家里设置诱杀装置或准备围攻。因此，决定
target Darren while he was away from his home. This would also prevent him from destroying any evidence or arming himself with any weapons that might be stashed on the premises. or arming himself with any weapons that might be stashed on the premises. On Thursday, January 7, 2021, four months after Jamie's murder, investigators followed Darren as he was out driving with one of his daughters. After they pulled into a parking spot, police made their approach. Against expectations, Darren exited the vehicle calmly and offered no resistance when placed in handcuffs. He was quiet and appeared nervous upon learning of the multi-state police operation that had been carried out under his nose. In a subsequent police interview, Darren denied having been to D to Dallas, though he did admit
在达伦离开家时针对他采取行动。这也将防止他销毁任何证据或用可能藏在房产内的任何武器武装自己。在房产内可能藏有的任何武器。2021年1月7日星期四，即杰米被谋杀四个月后，调查人员在达伦开车带着他的一个女儿外出时跟踪了他。在他们驶入停车位后，警察进行了接近。出乎意料的是，达伦冷静地走下车，在被戴上手铐时没有反抗。他很安静，在得知在他眼皮底下进行的跨州警察行动后显得很紧张。在随后的警察审讯中，达伦否认去过达拉斯，但他确实承认
to knowing Jennifer Faith. He became misty-eyed as he recalled memories of their youth together, saying they'd reconnected online almost a year prior. According to Darren, his relationship with the Jennifer was just friendly. She was using her expertise as a therapist to help him get through a difficult divorce. Darren believed that Jennifer had been happily married and he maintained that he hadn't crossed any inappropriate lines. When Darren was queried about the tea sticker that had been removed from his truck, he abruptly shut down and demanded an attorney.
认识詹妮弗·费斯。当他回忆起他们年轻时的记忆时，他眼眶湿润，说他们大约一年前在网上重新建立了联系。据达伦说，他和詹妮弗的关系只是友好的。她利用她作为治疗师的专业知识帮助他度过了一场艰难的离婚。达伦相信詹妮弗一直婚姻幸福，他坚持认为他没有越过任何不适当的界限。当达伦被问及从他卡车上取下的T型贴纸时，他突然沉默并要求聘请律师。
Meanwhile, police were undertaking a search of Darren's ranch in Tennessee. On his front porch was a large, narrow cardboard box featuring the logo of shipping company FedEx. It was addressed from Jennifer to Darren. The box was empty, but officers soon found what it had contained in Darren's living room, a brand new 55-inch flat-screen television. The filthy state of Darren's house was unlike anything the officers had ever seen. They described it as deplorable and took it as a major sign that Darren was mentally unwell and struggling to cope. Officers had to dig through piles of clothes, trash, old food, and clutter in search for evidence. They came across more packages from Jennifer,
与此同时，警方正在搜查达伦在田纳西州的牧场。在他的前廊上有一个大的、窄的纸板箱，上面印有航运公司FedEx的标志。它是从詹妮弗寄给达伦的。箱子是空的，但警察很快在达伦的客厅里发现了它里面装的东西，一台全新的55英寸平板电视。达伦房子的肮脏程度是警察从未见过的。他们将其描述为令人痛心，并将其视为达伦精神不健康且难以应对的一个重大迹象。警察不得不翻找成堆的衣服、垃圾、旧食物和杂物来寻找证据。他们发现了更多来自詹妮弗的包裹，
as well as some letters she wrote to Darren. In one, she referred to him as her soulmate. In another, she called him her one and only love. An array of ammunition was found all over the house, in boxes and loosely scattered about. On the floor near Darren's bed was a tan-coloured military-style satchel. Inside was a DVD and some snacks that Darren had purchased at the gas station while en route to Dallas in October 2020. There was also a rolled-up t-shirt. Officers unravelled the shirt to find that it contained a loaded Smith & Wesson 45-calibre silver handgun. Its barrel was smeared with a discoloured substance. The unregistered gun was traced to a foreign firearms dealer in Belgium. When tested, it produced imprints on the bullet casings that matched those recovered from the scene of Jamie
以及一些她写给达伦的信。在其中一封信中，她称他为她的灵魂伴侣。在另一封信中，她称他为她唯一的爱人。房子里到处都是各种弹药，有的装在盒子里，有的散乱着。在达伦床边的地板上有一个棕褐色的军用风格挎包。里面有一张DVD和一些达伦在2020年10月前往达拉斯途中在加油站购买的零食。还有一件卷起来的T恤。警察展开T恤，发现里面藏着一把装满子弹的史密斯威森45口径银色手枪。枪管上沾着一种变色的物质。这把未注册的枪支被追溯到比利时的一家外国枪支经销商。经测试，它在弹壳上留下的印记与从杰米·费斯枪击现场回收的弹壳相匹配。
Faith's shooting. Furthermore, the discoloured substance on the barrel was confirmed to be Jamie's blood. The discovery of the murder weapon was surprising. Given that Darren had several months to get rid of the gun or at least clean it up, investigators wondered if he had held onto it as a trophy. At the same time that Darren Lopez was placed under arrest, police conducted another interview with Jennifer Faith. They wanted to get all the information they could from her before she found out Darren was in custody in case she stopped cooperating entirely. Jennifer maintained the same story she'd been telling from the outset about the unknown dark-eyed gunman. Then, for the first time, a detective asked her,
此外，枪管上的变色物质被证实是杰米的血。凶器的发现令人惊讶。考虑到达伦有几个月的时间来处理掉这把枪或至少清理干净，调查人员怀疑他是否把它当作战利品保留了下来。在达伦·洛佩兹被捕的同时，警方对詹妮弗·费斯进行了另一次审讯。他们想在她发现达伦被拘留之前从她那里获取所有信息，以防她完全停止合作。詹妮弗坚持她从一开始就讲述的关于那个身份不明的黑眼枪手的相同故事。然后，侦探第一次问她，
Have you ever heard the name Darren? Jennifer became noticeably tense. She explained that Darren was her former high school boyfriend. When asked why she'd never mentioned him, Jennifer paused for a moment before saying that she hadn't seen Darren since 1993. She was then presented with the phone data proving she and Darren had sent hundreds of thousands of texts in the past year, with the detective telling her, I know there's more to you and Darren's relationship. Jennifer replied staunchly, I don't know what you're talking about. The detective pressed on, taking Jennifer back to Friday, October 9, 2020. Personally, in my heart, I believe you know what happened that day, he said.
“你听说过达伦这个名字吗？”詹妮弗明显变得紧张起来。她解释说达伦是她高中的前男友。当被问及为什么她从未提到过他时，詹妮弗停顿了一会儿，然后说她自1993年以来就没见过达伦。然后她被出示了证明她和达伦在过去一年里互发了数十万条短信的手机数据，侦探告诉她：“我知道你和达伦的关系不止于此。”詹妮弗坚定地回答：“我不知道你在说什么。”侦探继续追问，将詹妮弗带回2020年10月9日星期五。“就我个人而言，在我的内心深处，我相信你知道那天发生了什么，”他说。
I'm going to tell you like this, Jennifer. I know that Darren killed your husband. Jennifer flat out rejected the accusation. She admitted that she and Darren had recently been in contact and were caught up in old emotions, but she said she'd put an end to anything romantic in August 2020. Since then, Jennifer said they were just friends and claimed she was helping Darren navigate through tough times. The interviewing detective said, The same guy that killed your husband is the same guy that you're communicating with every day. How could you talk to somebody that killed your husband? Jennifer appeared to be shocked.
“我要这样告诉你，詹妮弗。我知道达伦杀了你的丈夫。”詹妮弗断然拒绝了这一指控。她承认她和达伦最近有联系，并且陷入了旧情，但她说她在2020年8月结束了任何浪漫关系。从那时起，詹妮弗说他们只是朋友，并声称她是在帮助达伦度过难关。审讯的侦探说：“那个杀了你丈夫的人，就是你每天都在联系的那个人。你怎么能和一个杀了你丈夫的人说话？”詹妮弗显得很震惊。
killed your husband." Jennifer appeared to be shocked. I wouldn't do that. Why would I do that? she replied. I didn't know he killed my husband. I still don't know that he killed my husband. The fact that Jennifer had led the police to so many dead ends made them suspect that she was lying to protect Darren. What they couldn't figure out was why she didn't just leave Jamie if she no longer wanted to be with him. Why did he have to die? When presented with this question, Jennifer stopped talking and asked for an attorney. Jennifer's assertions highlighted a major issue in the unravelling case. Despite everything
“杀了你丈夫。”詹妮弗显得很震惊。“我不会那样做。我为什么要那样做？”她回答。“我不知道他杀了我的丈夫。我仍然不知道他杀了我的丈夫。”詹妮弗将警察引向如此多死胡同的事实使他们怀疑她在撒谎以保护达伦。他们无法弄清楚的是，如果她不再想和杰米在一起，为什么她不直接离开他。为什么他必须死？当被问及这个问题时，詹妮弗停止了说话并要求聘请律师。詹妮弗的断言突显了这起正在解开的案件中的一个重大问题。尽管到目前为止已经揭露了一切，
that had been uncovered so far, investigators still hadn't found any evidence of Jennifer scheming with Darren to remove Jamie from the picture or encouraging him to kill. Just because the two had remained in contact after Jamie was killed, it didn't prove Jennifer was involved in the crime. The question therefore remained as to what role, if any, she played in her husband's murder. Investigators hoped that the answers would be found in Darren's cell phone, which they had swiftly confiscated upon his arrest. Despite leaving him with no time to interact with the device, it appeared to have already been wiped clean of any of his communications with the Jennifer. It was assumed that Darren had
调查人员仍然没有找到任何詹妮弗与达伦密谋除掉杰米或鼓励他杀人的证据。仅仅因为两人在杰米被杀后保持联系，并不能证明詹妮弗参与了犯罪。因此，问题仍然是她在她丈夫的谋杀案中扮演了什么角色（如果有的话）。调查人员希望在达伦的手机中找到答案，他们在达伦被捕时迅速没收了该手机。尽管没有给他时间与设备互动，但它似乎已经被清除了任何他与詹妮弗的通信记录。人们认为达伦已经
performed a factory reset, but a data extraction was conducted regardless. It turned out that Darren wasn't particularly tech savvy. While he had managed to permanently delete most of his text message history with the Jennifer, he had failed to completely erase all the data. Despite Darren and Jennifer's claims of a platonic friendship, the recovered texts revealed that their relationship was indeed intimate. Darren texted Jennifer things like, I am so in love with you, to which she responded, I truly can't be without you at this point. Jennifer suggested that she move in with Darren, which he thought was a great idea. The pair also engaged in many explicit sexual conversations both before and after Jamie's murder.
执行了恢复出厂设置，但无论如何还是进行了数据提取。事实证明，达伦并不是特别精通技术。虽然他成功地永久删除了他与詹妮弗的大部分短信历史，但他未能完全擦除所有数据。尽管达伦和詹妮弗声称是柏拉图式的友谊，但恢复的短信显示他们的关系确实很亲密。达伦给詹妮弗发短信说：“我太爱你了”，她回应说：“此时此刻，我真的不能没有你。”詹妮弗建议她搬去和达伦住，他认为这是一个好主意。两人在杰米被谋杀前后也进行了许多露骨的性对话。
Some were extreme, centering around topics like dominance, submission, bondage, voyeurism, and even rape. The most compelling messages were in relation to the ongoing investigation into Jamie's murder. After Jennifer made a public appeal to find the suspect's vehicle, she texted Darren, So I woke up in a little bit of a panic. Something is eating away at me telling me you need to take the sticker out of the back window of the truck. It might just be me overthinking or something, but I'll feel a ton better if you take it off and clean the window really well. Darren assured Jennifer that he would take care of it, but by the next day she was increasingly anxious. I know you're going to think I'm crazy, she messaged Darren, but it's really nagging at me.
有些很极端，围绕着支配、服从、束缚、窥淫癖甚至强奸等话题。最引人注目的信息与对杰米谋杀案的持续调查有关。在詹妮弗公开呼吁寻找嫌疑人的车辆后，她给达伦发短信说：“我醒来时有点恐慌。有什么东西在啃噬着我，告诉我你需要把卡车后窗上的贴纸取下来。可能只是我多虑了什么的，但如果你把它取下来并把窗户擦得很干净，我会感觉好多了。”达伦向詹妮弗保证他会处理好，但到第二天她越来越焦虑。“我知道你会觉得我疯了，”她给达伦发信息，“但这真的让我很烦。
I have a bad feeling and I really think you need to get that sticker off ASAP, like today. He later messaged her, Stick it done. Jennifer replied, Oh yay, I feel so much better. In other messages, Jennifer told Darren that if the police ever asked about her, he should say they were old friends. They were only speaking daily because Jennifer was giving him advice as he went through a difficult divorce. She told Darren to say that as far as he knew, her marriage to Jamie was a happy one. She also added Darren to the private group
我有一种不好的预感，我真的认为你需要尽快把那个贴纸取下来，比如今天。”他后来给她发信息：“贴纸搞定了。”詹妮弗回答：“哦耶，我感觉好多了。”在其他信息中，詹妮弗告诉达伦，如果警察问起她，他应该说他们是老朋友。他们只是每天都在说话，因为詹妮弗在他经历艰难离婚时给他建议。她告诉达伦说，据他所知，她和杰米的婚姻是幸福的。她还将达伦添加到了私人群组
text message thread that she used to keep her close friends and family updated on her husband's case. At one stage, she complained to Darren about having to do a press interview as Jamie's bereaved widow, saying, "...the reporter sucked, but I did fine. He insisted on having me look at a stupid photo book of Jamie at the end. Baff." On multiple occasions, Jennifer told Darren she was clearing her phone by doing a factory reset and she instructed him to do the same. When Darren thought he had done so, Jennifer replied, Big smile over here at that. At one point, Jennifer and Darren discussed Jamie's life insurance policy, which was worth
短信线程中，她用它来让她的密友和家人了解她丈夫案件的最新情况。有一次，她向达伦抱怨作为杰米的遗孀不得不接受媒体采访，说：“……记者很烂，但我表现得很好。最后他坚持让我看一本杰米的愚蠢相册。笨蛋。”在多次场合，詹妮弗告诉达伦她正在通过恢复出厂设置来清理手机，并指示他也这样做。当达伦认为他已经这样做时，詹妮弗回答：“这里有个大大的微笑。”有一次，詹妮弗和达伦讨论了杰米的人寿保险单，价值
over $600,000. Jennifer was the sole beneficiary, while Jamie also had a further $400,000 in a retirement account. A month after Jamie's murder, Jennifer had attempted to collect some of the money, but she was denied. She vented about it in a text to Darren saying, "...they aren't processing the claim yet because the detectives told them I couldn't be ruled out as a suspect, so I called them and basically said, what the fuck?" The pair discussed using the money to apply for a residence in Jennifer's name in Tennessee.
超过60万美元。詹妮弗是唯一的受益人，而杰米在退休账户中还有40万美元。在杰米被谋杀一个月后，詹妮弗曾试图领取部分钱款，但被拒绝了。她在给达伦的短信中发泄说：“……他们还没有处理索赔，因为侦探告诉他们我不能被排除在嫌疑人之外，所以我给他们打了电话，基本上说，这到底是怎么回事？”两人讨论用这笔钱以詹妮弗的名义在田纳西州申请住所。
Jennifer was also the sole beneficiary of the $60,000 in donations collected via the online fundraiser for Jamie's funeral services. She began withdrawing from these funds almost immediately. Within four days she had taken out over $30,000 and within weeks there was nothing left. The two memorial services for Jamie had only cost Jennifer $6,000, which she hadn't even paid. Credit reports reflected that by 2020 Darren Lopez was having severe financial problems. He was at least 120 days past due on mortgage payments totaling over $38,000 and foreclosure had been initiated. In October, failure to pay his water bills
詹妮弗也是通过在线筹款活动为杰米的葬礼服务收集的6万美元捐款的唯一受益人。她几乎立即开始从这些资金中提款。在四天内，她取出了超过3万美元，几周内就什么都不剩了。杰米的两次追悼会只花费了詹妮弗6000美元，她甚至还没付钱。信用报告显示，到2020年，达伦·洛佩兹正面临严重的财务问题。他的抵押贷款逾期至少120天，总额超过3.8万美元，并且已经启动了止赎程序。10月份，未能支付水费
resulted in the water to his house being shut off. Online records showed that Jennifer had transferred large amounts of money to Darren after Jamie's murder. She had also bought him the new television, airline tickets and had granted him access to her credit cards, texting, "'Please don't hesitate to use them for whatever you need." Jennifer used the money fundraised on her behalf to help pay back over $100,000 that she and Darren had spent on the credit cards. She told Darren that if detectives ever asked why Jennifer was giving him money, he should say that she was supporting him through his financial hardship. He should say that she was supporting him through his financial hardship.
导致他家的水被切断。在线记录显示，詹妮弗在杰米被谋杀后向达伦转移了大量资金。她还给他买了新电视、机票，并允许他使用她的信用卡，发短信说：“请不要犹豫，用它们买你需要的东西。”詹妮弗利用以她的名义筹集的资金来帮助偿还她和达伦在信用卡上花费的超过10万美元。她告诉达伦，如果侦探问起为什么詹妮弗给他钱，他应该说她是在支持他度过财务困难。他应该说她是在支持他度过财务困难。
I'll answer the same way," she texted him. Just so you and I have the same explanations. Darren responded, I like it. With this evidence coming to light, investigators suspected that Jennifer had hired Darren to kill her husband. Given Darren's elite military training, not only was he the ideal hitman, he also had the financial and romantic motives to do so.
“我会用同样的回答，”她给他发短信。“这样你和我就有同样的解释了。”达伦回应：“我喜欢这个。”随着这些证据的曝光，调查人员怀疑詹妮弗雇佣了达伦来杀害她的丈夫。鉴于达伦的精英军事训练，他不仅是理想的杀手，而且还有财务和浪漫动机这样做。
But with no admissions from either party and no concrete evidence to prove it, it remained pure speculation. What was abundantly clear was that Jennifer Faith's private persona was very different from the grieving widow she portrayed in public. In reality, she was careful and cunning. She asserted that she had no idea who killed her husband, while keeping the man she was having an emotional affair with secret from investigators. She lied to her friend about ending things with Darren when she was still messaging him excessively. She provided false information and dead-end leads to misdirect the police and public. She coached Darren on how to respond to police questions and instigated the destruction of crucial evidence.
但由于双方都没有承认，也没有确凿的证据证明这一点，这仍然纯属猜测。显而易见的是，詹妮弗·费斯的私人形象与她在公众面前表现出的悲伤遗孀形象截然不同。实际上，她小心谨慎且狡猾。她声称不知道是谁杀了她的丈夫，同时对调查人员隐瞒了她正在进行婚外情的男人。她对朋友撒谎说结束了与达伦的关系，而实际上她仍在过度地给他发信息。她提供虚假信息和死胡同线索来误导警察和公众。她指导达伦如何回应警察的问题，并煽动销毁关键证据。
Investigators viewed Jennifer's conduct and corrupt actions as a calculated attempt to obstruct the criminal investigation. As a result, she was charged with obstruction of justice, to which she pleaded not guilty. Given that authorities still didn't have anything to prove Jennifer was complicit in her husband's murder, she was released pending further investigations. With suspicions cast squarely on her, detectives were curious to see her next move. They knew there was still more to uncover, but felt confident they were about to close the case. The situation appeared to be a sordid love triangle with fatal consequences, which was nothing that they hadn't seen before.
调查人员将詹妮弗的行为和腐败行为视为阻碍刑事调查的蓄意企图。因此，她被控妨碍司法公正，她对此表示不认罪。鉴于当局仍然没有任何证据证明詹妮弗是她丈夫谋杀案的共犯，她在等待进一步调查期间被释放。随着怀疑直接指向她，侦探们很好奇地想看看她的下一步行动。他们知道还有更多东西需要揭露，但相信他们即将结案。这种情况似乎是一个带有致命后果的肮脏三角恋，这并不是他们以前没见过的。
In the meantime, Darren Lopez was charged with the murder of Jamie Faith as well as transporting a firearm in interstate commerce. Case detectives were lauded for their dedicated and meticulous police work, with the chief of the Dallas Police Department saying, I am pleased to see that there were no stones left unturned during the course of this investigation and that our collaborative efforts have brought those involved to justice." Darren Lopez pleaded not guilty and was remanded in custody to await his trial. Meanwhile, Jennifer Faith asked a third party to forward a
与此同时，达伦·洛佩兹被控谋杀杰米·费斯以及在州际贸易中运输枪支。案件侦探因其专注和细致的警察工作而受到赞扬，达拉斯警察局局长说：“我很高兴看到在这次调查过程中没有遗漏任何细节，我们的合作努力已将相关人员绳之以法。”达伦·洛佩兹表示不认罪，并被还押候审。与此同时，詹妮弗·费斯要求第三方转发一条
message onto Darren in jail. Aware that all their communications would be monitored, Jennifer just wanted Darren to know that she was with him and would always be with him, no matter what had happened. It was an intriguing comment that seemed to support Jennifer's claims that she didn't know the full extent of Darren's actions. Yet she remained unfazed and fully committed to him even though he was charged with the Jamie's murder. Jennifer told her messenger, Please tell Darren ASAP I will always be his. Darren responded to Jennifer via the messenger, saying, "'Please stay strong for us.' He referred to himself as her knight, a noble and
信息给监狱里的达伦。意识到他们所有的通信都会被监控，詹妮弗只是想让达伦知道她和他在一起，无论发生了什么，她都会永远和他在一起。这是一个耐人寻味的评论，似乎支持了詹妮弗声称她不知道达伦行为的全部程度的说法。然而，尽管他被控谋杀杰米，她仍然泰然自若并完全致力于他。詹妮弗告诉她的传信人：“请尽快告诉达伦，我永远是他的。”达伦通过传信人回应詹妮弗说：“请为我们坚强起来。”他称自己为她的骑士，一个高尚且
chivalrous warrior charged with protecting her." As Darren's trial loomed, his ex-wife began taking care of several financial matters on his behalf. In order to do this, Darren gave her access to his email account. As she navigated his inbox, she came across something shocking. To be continued next week you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
英勇的战士，负责保护她。”随着达伦审判的临近，他的前妻开始代表他处理几项财务事宜。为了做到这一点，达伦给了她访问他电子邮件账户的权限。当她浏览他的收件箱时，她发现了一些令人震惊的事情。下周继续，您目前还没有关于这一集的评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。